راعي الاغنام وتربيتها هو مصدر الرزق
الوحيد لاهالي هذا التجمع البدوي الذين
فقدوا ويفقدون اغنامهم يوما بعد يوم
[موسيقى]
لان نحن بنعتبرها بدك الصحيح والله قنبله
موجوده في الارض يعني صحيح وتسرب منها
الموده السامه هذه قال الغنم تشرب منها
ابتسامه بتموت قالوا اولاد بسيبهم مرض في
رجليهم وحكوا اشي زي هيك
البدو الذين يعيشون قرب مكان بالعيزريه
هؤلاء ناس يستحقون الحياه ولديهم اطفال
ولديهم ماشيه ونتغذى جميعا من منتجاتهم
ينتجون الحليب وينتجون اللحوم ومنتجات
الالبان فلا ندري ماذا نتناول نحن من هذه
المنتجات اذا كنا لا تهمنا صحتهم على
الاقل سوف تهمنا صحتنا اليس كذلك الترحيل
الممنهج العربي الجهالين من المناطق
الواسعه من المراعي من طريقه تربيه
الاغنام اللي هي في النهايه حتصل السوق
الفلسطيني والسوق الاسرائيلي ايضا ليس فقط
السوق الفلسطيني ملوثه وتتراكم داخل
الاجساد البشر